bonjour dans cette émission nous avons
beaucoup parlé des saints bande dessinée
le maul dit il ya beaucoup de dessins
dans une bande dessinée mais ce dessin
en réalité est toujours au service d'une
histoire
alors cette histoire elle s'appelle pas
une histoire vous avez sûrement entendu
prononcer le mot de scénario c'est le
même mot qui sert en bande dessinée au
cinéma d'ailleurs
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'un scénario
est bien le scénario c'est ce qui va se
passer
il se rédige au départ exactement comme
une rédaction à l'école il ya un début
de l'histoire
il ya une fin de l'histoire puis il ya
ce qui se passe entre les deux qu'on
appelle le développement
alors là vous vous racontez votre petite
histoire en sachant que vous allez faire
une histoire en bande dessinée de cette
page de huit pages ou de 40 pages votre
récit sera plus ou moins long mais vous
le raconter exactement comme une
rédaction ça fait une ou deux pages
manuscrites
ça c'est la base à partir de là on entre
dans la technique de la bande dessinée
qui s'appelle le découpage je suis dans
un découpage
c'est très mystérieux on y voit des
lettres des colonnes des descriptions du
dialogue
il y a même un code c'est de la chimie
tout ça paraît vraiment être l'univers
des professionnels en réalité il suffit
de connaître certains trucs
quand je vous ai quitté un peu
brusquement à l'instant je me promenais
donc dans une page de scénarios a grandi
ou plus exactement une page découper du
scénario des aventures d'achille talon
alors imaginons que vous êtes scénariste
et vous travaillez avec un dessinateur
ceci ça va servir à vous comprendre
entre vous le scénariste et le
dessinateur s'est pas destiné au public
alors on indique d'abord le nom de la
série l'histoire et le numéro de la page
à laquelle nous sommes parce que pelé
cirad page puis son risque de confondre
nous avons trois colonnes la première on
va y revenir tout de suite
on y lit des lettres et des chiffres
voilà je fais à 1 2 3 puis je passe à b1
doucet très mystérieux ici la partie la
plus simple c'est le dialogue c'est
écrit sous forme dactylographié ou autre
ce qui va venir dessiner dans les bulles
dans les ballons quand les personnages
vont parler entre eux dans l'image est
ici au milieu la partie la plus
importante qui est la description écrite
par le scénariste de ce que le
dessinateur va devoir précisément
dessinée alors là ça lui est très court
et pour que ce soit court il faut qu'on
se comprenne du premier coup le
dessinateur a préparé l'autre bout de la
filière imaginons que le scénariste
habite marseille le dessinateur paris
échanges par correspondance et le
dessinateur a préparé lui déjà dès lors
il cela fait de scénario on verra
l'instant et lui il va traduire tout de
suite alors la première bande
pour lui c'est la bande à l'autre b
l'autre c'est l'autre dès la page
standard il y a douze images
si le scénariste a prévu qui aurait 12
images on changerait ça va être à 1 à 2
à 3 v 1 b2 b3 et ainsi de suite c'est
exactement comme à la bataille navale
mais imaginons que le scénariste sentent
que il doit s'exprimer à certains en
mordant
de grandes images il en veut une plus
grande que d'habitude et il dit du
premier coup à 1-2 le dessinateur a
compris à 1 2 l'image va occuper les
deux tiers de la première bande il y
aura une image à 3 puis reprend à ab de
m maintenant il faut une toute grande je
le scénariste indique ab 1 2 1 2 le
dessinateur aussitôt c'est que son image
va être aussi grande que ça et on va
lire à 3 après petites images normales
b trois petites images normales c'est un
petit images normales up de nouveaux
grands desseins c2 c3 d2 d3 et grâce à
ce petit code qu'on peut perfectionner
quand on se connaît bien en général le
sénateur
le dessinateur et scénariste ont un peu
copains enfin il vaut mieux et ils
peuvent entre eux m un code au point un
code personnel et puis dans les colonnes
du milieu les descriptions d'image on va
lire des termes étrange par exemple un
panoramique
c'est un terme de cinéma a pas de bandes
dessinées apparemment apparemment
seulement bon en cinéma d'abord
qu'est-ce que c'est un panoramique
le plus simple c'est de vous en montrer
s'il vous plaît messieurs un petit
panoramic alors voilà un superbe
panoramique qui vous permet au passage
de découvrir le mobilier extraordinaire
dont nous disposons voilà et on revient
à la bande dessinée où il est très
possible de faire un panoramique
je vous explique comment là on va
imaginer un petit scénario
imaginons sur cette image que notre
héros super gérard au volant de sa
puissante voiture poursuit un bandit
redoutable le bandit redoutable celle
horrible succube et super gérard va-t-il
le rattrape et j'ai fait déjà un dessin
où on sent qu'il ya du chemin à
parcourir pour super g ral un énorme
chemin si mon dessin est plus grand
l'oeil du lecteur court vers la droite
s'aperçoit que la route reste encore
longue
si j'augmente encore on s'aperçoit que
super gérard va mettre un certain moment
avant de rattraper
l'horrible succube si un homme a donné
gagne du terrain donc panoramique à se
raccourcir et on va sentir que ça
devient tangent pour le succube qui va
passer un mauvais quart d'heure n'aura
pas volé bien il y à d'autres trucs de
cinéma qu'on peut également appliquer en
bande dessinée ou du moins donner la
même impression par exemple avez vous
déjà entendu parler d'un zoom et bien
jumeaux cinéma c'est ça alors voilà me
fait un très joli zou et bien ce zoom on
peut le reproduire en bande dessinée
aussi lassé du pam qui m'apprêtais le
personnage au cubitus que vous
connaissez sûrement
alors là on a cubitus à une certaine
distance il vient vers nous et puis
cubitus à la deuxième image se
rapprochent déjà beaucoup et à la
troisième image
il est tout près nous eh bien si ces
trois images sont alignés sur une même
bande
l'oeil du lecteur va faire le travail de
la caméra il va avoir l'impression que
cubitus vient de se rapprocher
terriblement vite et il a fait un zoom
si le scénariste zoom à son dessinateur
le dessinateur sera traduire en trois
images il y a
d'autres noms du cinéma mais vous la
trouvez bien vous même par exemple une
plongée quand ses vues du ciel une
contre-plongée quand vous imaginez que
la caméra est au sol et que vous
regardez vers le ciel et le reste je
crois que vous le découvrirez vous même
regardez attentivement les films de
cinéma
vous découvrirez le langage du scénario
le langage de la narration par l'image
filmée ou dessiner